das ist zb die automaten ehrt füße und
augen das alles erwartet uns wenn die
kernkraft uns weitergeleitet
[Musik]
hallo kinder heute gehe ich mal meinen
uralten nachbarn besuchen ganz ein
wasser gar nicht mehr halten aber
trotzdem streit kommt man mit
[Musik]
ein riss
warum sind belgische atomkraftwerke
besonders sicher kontrolliert werden
ja keine einfache frage ich verstehen
jedes akw hat ein handbuch ja und in
diesem handbuch ist alles beschrieben
was passieren könnte kw und darin ist
auch beschrieben was die leute machen
soll
ok und dafür zu sorgen dass ja gehts
also wenn du so ein ding explodiert so
schnell wie möglich weg laufen das schon
länger ja das ist der teenie der wohnt
in der nähe von zum atomkraftwerke sieht
man weil er nur vier finger hat so und
dann erst einmal gemacht
nach einer zeit verliert auf einmal
seine haare weil das atomkraftwerk in
der nähe ist ist natürlich auch für
andere seite nicht so schlimm aber er
hat rote haare und da ist er ganz froh
das hat nicht mal hat aber dann auf
einmal guckt der teenie aus dem fenster
und dann brennt es in dem atomkraftwerk
die leute sind natürlich ein bisschen
aufgeregt aber trotzdem macht dann auf
einmal um und das atomkraftwerk
explodiert für den teenie ist es
natürlich nicht schlecht denn endlich
ist mal was los in seiner gegend und
dann auf einmal jäh die kühe die liegen
auf der wiese und sind tot aber auf
anderen seite braucht der teenie dann
nicht mehr weil er laktose-intoleranz
hat die nicht vergeht und freut sich
darüber dass siegenthaler gibt und dann
hat er neue freunde gefunden und das ist
zb via tomate die hat füße und augen das
alles erwartet uns wenn die kernkraft
uns weitergeleitet
richtig nein das ist nicht ganz richtig
zum beispiel wenn wirklich etwas
schlimmes passiert lkw da werde alle
kühe von den wiesen geholt diese nach
außen ja auch zu mcdonald's wir werden
auch das nicht essen
dafür werden dann die ja wirklich und
die deutschen behörden auch so man also
sie können so gesehen auch sagen dass
die belgische regierung verbieten wird
das atomare strahlung nach außen dringt
auch nach deutschland kommt also wenn
ihr braucht nicht sagen kernkraft ist
total sicher und jetzt abschalten süßen
guten tag könnte ich sie für ein abo des
heute show you tube kanal als begeistern
schließt gefälligst ein abo ab sofort